in a world facing the effects of climate
change rising sea levels have forced
Humanity to seek refuge in space where
shelters are constructed between Earth
and the Moon Over time shelters 8 12 and
13 unite to form the Adrian Republic
engaging in a long war with the Allied
force on Earth the surviving humans
struggled to survive Captain Jung Yi a
legendary Soldier emerges as the Army's
most skilled warrior in an abandoned
town she battles against humanoid robots
with precision and resourcefulness
dispatching them effortlessly but her
Victory is short-lived when a strange
quadrupedal robot appears Jung Yi
realizes the danger and tried to shoot
the robot from a special spot and
manages to hit it with a blast however
the robot quickly turns back on and
repairs itself with its built-in
extinguishers desperate to overcome the
situation Jung Yi sets a trap using
metal beams successfully trapping the
machine however as she prepares for the
final blow she becomes distracted by a
small doll hanging from a car's
rear-view mirror this robot uses this
distraction to strike first pushing
jungi backward and injuring her as she
observes the injury Jung Yi discovers
the horrible truth there's Machinery
under her skin telling her that she
herself is not a human but an Android
suddenly an alarm sounds and the town
vanishes it is revealed that the world
she was in was not real and she is not
the real Jung Yi who actually died years
ago a group of scientists has been using
a copy of her brain to develop the
perfect Soldier Android however they are
slowed down by an unresolved mistake
that keeps causing jungi's repeated
defeats Jung Yi's daughter SEO Hyun
leads the project and witnesses her
mother's face endure countless deaths
SEO Hyun Works tirelessly with newcomer
Jake young to identify the problem in
their latest android model as jungi's
Consciousness awakens within the Android
she feels sudden distress when she
realizes her robotic form SEO Hyun
deactivates the Android's pain sensors
and demands answers from the team while
thinking about her mother's sacrifice
one day while SEO Hyun is riding a train
she sees a mother interacting with her
child triggering memories of her own
mother she recalls the day Yong Yi left
for battle promising to return already
overwhelmed by emotions seohyun visits
the doctor after taking her annual
ethics test where the doctor confirms
the return of her lung tumor and tells
her that she only has three months to
live the doctor suggests transferring
seohyun's brain to a prosthetic body and
mentions the various options available
type A is expensive but offers
protection type B is cheaper but comes
with certain rights limitations and type
c is the cheapest but allows the company
to create copies of the brain data to
create clones SEO Hyun leaves the doctor
and realizes he too is an Android she
remembers the agreement made to use her
mother's brain on Androids questioning
whether it was the right decision while
thinking this she visits her comatose
mother and prepares to test a new copy
of the brain in a simulation sang Hoon
the director of the program wanting a
different result orders the team to
shoot the Android in the leg before the
simulation begins as Jung Yi wakes up
she is experiencing intense pain from
the wound despite the suffering she
finds the strength to stand up and
continues fighting defeating the robot
with her fists before succumbing to
another enemy's shot the next day song
hoon is excited to showcase the new
brain to the higher-ups at the company
headquarters however they are greeted by
a new head of the product development
department who doesn't take sang Hoon
seriously and giggles at him sang Hoon
worries that weapons development might
be downsized but as concerns go unheard
and the team is sent away without
answers on their way back to the labs
sunghoon insults the new employee and
vows to keep the Chairman's dream alive
some days later the team receives news
that the chairman is coming to see them
as they enter the office song Hoon
suddenly freezes revealing that he is an
Android built by replicating the
Chairman's brain although he himself is
still unaware of this fact the chairman
arrives with important news a treaty is
being signed indicating the end of the
war and reduced need for weapons however
the chairman believes that the research
on Jung Yi was not in vain as it
provided insights into developing
Advanced AIS for other purposes the
chairman confesses that he wanted to
transfer his brain to sang Hoon for
immortality but chose to copy it instead
as this is happening SEO Hyun expresses
her desire to continue her mother's
project but the chairman rejects her
request the team returns to work knowing
the project must be wrapped up continues
to die repeatedly at the same spot
frustrating sang Hoon who can't activate
the new brain area to solve this issue
he starts to entertain more extreme
ideas song Hoon orders the team to
activate the Android and cut her arm
causing SEO Hyun to witness her mother's
excruciating pain the brain area still
refuses to light up in desperation sang
Hoon shoots the Android's legs to
recreate the previous wound seohyun
snaps and turns off the system to end
jungi's suffering angering sunghoon
before the situation escalates further
another employee interrupts them
informing sunghoon that the chairman
wants to see him he leaves without a
word and SEO Hyun thanks the team for
their work it's time to shut down the
project but seohyun asked the team to
Center all the data they've collected
sometime later SEO Hyun discovers that
someone has exported her mother's brain
without her knowledge intrigued she
investigates and finds Jake young her
co-worker engaging in Intimate
activities with an Android wearing
jungi's face devastated SEO Hyun
confronts Jake Young Who explains they
created companions capable of intimacy
using jungi's brain the Revelation
leaves in tears SEO Hyun returns to
spend time with the Android before the
project is taken away sang hoon is
already there consumed by depression
xiaohyun wakes up jungi telling her they
rescued her from the enemy but she is
Gravely wounded as SEO Hyun is about to
deactivate her the desired brain area
lights up again Jung Yi asks if her
daughter survived the surgery seohyun
breaks down realizing the brain area
reacted because jungi believed she would
die without knowing about her daughter
SEO Hyun reassures her that the surgery
was successful and Jung Yi finds peace
jungi admits feeling guilty for losing
the doll her daughter gave her
overwhelmed xio Hyun turns off the
Android and experiences a complete
breakdown in the moment of Despair SEO
Hyun realizes there is one last thing
she can do the next day she requests a
final simulation before shutting
everything down she sets up alone and
deletes the unidentified part of Jung
Yi's brain whispering in jungi's ear SEO
Hyun explains the dire consequences if
they don't take action after the
simulation during the final simulation
Jung Yi pretends to be shot and falls in
the usual spot sanghon Witnesses is this
peculiar act and rushes back to the lab
to review the simulation in slow motion
he confirms that jungi hadn't been shot
she had only pretended as seung-hoon
activates the alarm jungi incapacitates
the employees taking her away SEO Hyun
deletes all the original project data
Jung Yi discovers a room filled with
robots resembling her and faces sang
hoon's security robots with her fighting
skills she defeats multiple opponents
but one robot pushes her against a wall
xiaohyun arrives in time to disable the
attacking robot she and Jung Yi realize
they are in this together a new wave of
security robots arrives allowing SEO
Hyun to escape with another Android
escort they discovered jungi's physical
form is empty so Hyun had transferred
her brain copy to a security Android
deceiving the security Personnel SEO
Hyun takes jungi on a train where song
Hoon confronts them sang Hoon shoots
seohyun prompting Jung Yi to retaliate
sang Hoon freezes upon seeing his
reflection revealing his true identity
as an Android sang Hoon attacks Jung Yi
starting a brutal fight he manages to
push her through the window but she
crawls back in more security robots
arrive on a parallel train and the wag
are connected Jung Yi defeats the robots
while sang Hoon catches her with a hook
siohyun shoots a hook for jungi to grab
and she returns safely to the first
wagon the second wagon with seung-hoon
inside falls from the track as the
second wagon Falls the train stops in a
mountainous area jungi tends to see oh
hyun's wound but they hear the police
approaching SEO Hyun tells jungi to run
away and start a new life they say their
goodbyes and jungi flees through the
mountains seeking refuge and relishing
in her Newfound Freedom SEO Hyun dies
alone feeling closure click on one of
the videos on the screen now
foreign